bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat dans un instant vous allez pouvoir
suivre l'examen d'une proposition de
résolution sur la mise en oeuvre de la
contribution économique territoriale
là c'est au tc ce nouvel impôt qui a été
créée pour compenser la perte des
recettes pour les collectivités
territoriales
après la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle à l'époque cette réforme
voulue par nicolas sarkozy avait suscité
la colère d'une partie des sénateurs ump
emmenés par jean-pierre raffarin il
avait menacé de ne pas voter ce texte en
l'état ils savaient donc obtenu du
gouvernement la mise en place d'une
clause de revoyure
le gouvernement s'était donc engagée à
remettre au parlement un rapport
tirant le bilan de la réforme de la tp
avant le 1er juin 2010 or ce rapport a
été remis tardivement il a été remis le
17 juin dernier
il reste incomplet aux yeux des
sénateurs qui s'inquiètent de l'état des
finances locales
il examine donc cette proposition de
résolution c'est une nouveauté issue de
la révision constitutionnelle cela n'a
pas vraiment de valeur législatif mais
c'est quand même un coup de semonce de
la majorité sénatoriale à quelques
heures vous le savez du début de
l'examen en séance de la réforme
territoriale tout de suite donc
direction l'hémicycle très bonne après
midi à tous sur public sénat
l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen de la
proposition de résolution relative à la
mise en oeuvre de la contribution
économique territoriale présentée en
application de l'article 34-1 de la
constitution par messieurs gérard
longuet nicolas bougeard thuy philippe
parini charles guené alain chatillon
françois noël buffet et les membres du
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
apparentés et rattachés et les membres
du groupe de l'union centriste et on
attend un ministre
madame la ministre bonjour et dans le
débat la parole et à monsieur philippe
parini coauteur de la proposition de
résolution
le président monsieur le cours de madame
le ministre mes chers collègues
il s'agit de la première proposition de
résolution soumise au sénat sur le
fondement de la nouvelle procédure
constitutionnelle et portant sur les
finances locales
c'est un symbole mes chers collègues une
marque de la détermination du sénat plus
particulièrement des deux groupes qui
sont à l'origine de ce texte à exercer
notre mission constitutionnelles de
représentants des collectivités
territoriales le sujet s'y prête
transformer la taxe professionnelle en
contribution économique territoriale est
un pari risqué
il faut faire en sorte de sortir avec
succès du processus dans lequel les
acteurs de la réforme sont entrés depuis
le 1er janvier 2010 je voudrais tout
d'abord me référer mes chers collègues à
la lettre de l'article 76 de la loi de
finances pour 2010
cet article n'est pas respecté à la
lettre
si cela avait été le cas nous ne serions
pas en train de débattre d'une
proposition de résolution mais d'un
texte législatif susceptibles d'être
promulguée avant le 31 juillet selon
l'article 76 en effet
la loi précise et adapte le dispositif
de répartition des ressources des
collectivités territoriales et des
établissements publics de coopération
intercommunale à fiscalité propre
elle met en place des mécanismes de
péréquation fondée sur les écarts de
potentiel financier et de charges entre
les collectivités territoriales
rappelons-nous mes chers collègues que
cet article a été voulu par le cdh a et
a été déterminant pour finaliser la
réforme de la taxe professionnelle
cette réforme à la ministre vous vous en
souvenez n'a pas été un long fleuve
tranquille et au demeurant j'ai tort
d'en parler au passé car ce n'est pas
terminé
le principe d'une mise en oeuvre de la
contribution économique territoriale
jalonnée de rendez vous réguliers nous
semble plus que jamais pertinent en
effet les conséquences de la suppression
de la part équipements et biens
mobiliers de la taxe professionnelle
vont bien au delà de celle de la
suppression de la part salaires en 1999
cette fois ci il s'agit d'une réforme
qui a un impact sur l'ensemble du
système de financement des collectivités
territoriales le rendement des impôts le
fonctionnement des fonds de péréquation
les modalités de répartition des
dotations
il est donc logique que les élus soient
préoccupés qu'il soit en tout cas
attentif il est tout aussi
compréhensible que nous entendions leur
inquiétude est que nous puissions les
relayer au sein de cette haute assemblée
le dispositif mis en place par la
réforme se situe dans la longue
tradition de complexité des finances
locales
c'est à dire que bien des subtilités ne
sont accessibles qu'aux seuls initiés
les conditions de l'intéressement des
entreprises à l'implantation les
conditions de l'intéressement des
collectivités territoriales à
l'implantation des entreprises était à
nos yeux
r sous l'ancien régime à ce stade
pour beaucoup d'entre nous elles ne sont
que théoriques dans le nouveau le sénat
s'était préparé madame le ministre à ce
rendez vous de juillet commission des
finances pour sa part a organisé
plusieurs tables rondes et ateliers de
travail sur les différents aspects de la
réforme et vous avez bien voulu y
apporter votre concours
le gouvernement a été lui même invité à
se préparer à ce rendez vous de juillet
et l'article 76 qui prescrivaient de
remettre un rapport avant le 1er juin le
gouvernement a missionné l'inspection
générale des finances l'inspection
générale de l'administration
il a fait sien le rapport ainsi déposé
quant aux simulations répondant aux
demandes formulées par la commission des
finances du sénat
il y a été effectivement répondu tout
dernièrement puisque ces chiffres sont
arrivés hier dimanche et n'ont pas pu je
vous le confesse être totalement
exploité la principale conclusion que
les signataires souhaitent proposer au
sénat est la suivante nous souhaitons
madame le ministre que le gouvernement
puisse nous présenter le chemin critique
la trajectoire de l'arrêt veut légiférer
trop tôt mes chers collègues ce serait
prendre un risque inutile et la
commission des finances pour ce qui la
concerne à cette conviction depuis déjà
plusieurs mois
elle se retrouve notamment dans un
communiqué de presse que nous avions
publié dès le 31 mars dernier une
nouvelle loi qui serait conçue à partir
de simulations qui ne serait guère plus
fiables que celles utilisées pendant
l'examen du projet de loi de finances
pour 2010 ne pourrait qu alimenter une
confusion supplémentaire en revanche il
est bien une annonce à ne plus repoussé
c'est le chemin critique c'est la
trajectoire de la réforme ce que nous
attendons de vous aujourd'hui madame le
ministre
est ce que la résolution invite le
gouvernement à présenter c'est l'
annonce détaillée des dates auxquelles
les différentes données seront connues
et en conséquence le calendrier des
modifications législatives
nous le savons bien mes chers collègues
la loi de finances pour 2011 sera le
premier rendez vous législatifs
intermédiaire mais que va contenir ce
rendez-vous et que sera ton en mesure
d'y faire figurer
nous rappelons par exemple dans la
proposition de résolution que les
notions de potentiel financier de
potentiel fiscal doivent être adaptées
pour que le système de répartition des
dotations continue de fonctionner pour
que les fonds de péréquation ne soit pas
asphyxier
il s'agit d'une question essentielle
on ne peut pas imaginer qu'elle ne soit
pas tranchée dans la prochaine loi de
finances pourra-t-on simultanément
traiter des instruments de mesure des
richesses et de répartition des
dotations et sans avoir mis à l'épreuve
les nouveaux instruments définir dans le
détail le nouveau système de péréquation
au sein du bloc communal ma réponse est
sans doute dans la question est à cet
égard il serait utile que le secrétaire
d'état aux collectivités territoriales
votre collègue puisse préciser à quoi il
faisait allusion lorsque le 22 juin
devant la commission des finances il a
annoncé l'inscription de dispositions
relatives à la péréquation dans le
projet de loi de finances pour 2011
l'absence de précipitations dans les
modifications législatives ne doit pas à
notre avis bien au contraire
r empêcher le gouvernement de nous faire
part de ses intentions
et ceci en particulier sur les points
suivants la proposition de résolution
est le souhait que soit annoncée le
cadre du dispositif de péréquation pour
le bloc communal la proposition de
résolution exprime également une vive
préoccupation de notre part quant au
statut de la dotation de compensation de
la réforme de la taxe professionnelle on
regarde l'enveloppent normes et des
concours financiers de l'état aux
collectivités territoriales
on sait depuis la loi de finances pour
2010 que ses attributions ne seront pas
indexé pas plus que les versements du
fonds national de la garantie
individuelle de ressources le fn gier
vous avez bien voulu madame le ministre
il y a quelques jours devant la
commission des finances élargi nous
indiquer que cette dotation n'avait pas
vocation à jouer le rôle de variable
d'ajustement de l' enveloppe normée
nous sommes nombreux à souhaiter que ces
assurances soit renouvelée car il s'agit
bien du principe sur lequel nous serons
intransigeants de la compensation à
l'euro près les élus les élus locaux
nos mandants pourront comprendre ainsi
que le rendez vous législatifs de
juillet soit repoussée mais à condition
que nous soyons capables de leur
présenter dès les prochaines semaines
une approche progressive et réaliste de
la mise en oeuvre de la réforme
en ce domaine comme dans d'autres
domaines madame le ministre
rien ne serait pire que le double
langage celui que l'on tiendrait aux
élus pour les rassurer et celui que l'on
tiendrait par ailleurs au sein des
administrations entre gens raisonnables
on ne peut pas se permettre sur un tel
sujet madame le ministre de miser sur
l'arrêt
ignatieff des élus et des parlementaires
maintenant une chose paraît sûre le
report des modifications législatives
n'est en rien à ce jour une source
d'incertitude supplémentaire pour les
élus locaux
en 2010 l'administration a très
correctement fait les choses s'agissant
de la notification des attributions au
titre de la compensation relais les
éléments de calcul apparaissait
clairement ainsi que le manteau rien ne
devrait être différent en 2011 car le
dispositif de compensation à l'euro près
garanties aux collectivités
territoriales une réelle visibilité sur
leurs ressources pour l'année 2011
en premier lieu chaque collectivité est
assuré de percevoir en 2011 pour
l'ensemble des ressources fiscales
affectés par la réforme
un montant équivalent à ce qu'elles
auraient perçu en 2010 en l'absence de
réformes
cette stabilité surtout dans l'état
actuel de l'économie est source de
visibilité on peut même penser qu'en
l'absence de réformes
le produit de taxe professionnelle de
l'année 2011 vous demande de bien
vouloir y réfléchir mes chers collègues
fondés sur les données économiques de
l'année 2009 année de crise aurait
probablement diminué en valeur pour une
bonne partie des collectivités de ce
point de vue et à court terme la réforme
est donc protectrice du point de vue
pratique maintenant l'administration
notifiera chaque collectivité comme pour
la compensation relais en 2010 les
montants de dotation de compensation de
la réforme de la taxe professionnelle et
d'attribution prélèvements au titre du
fonds national de garantie individuelle
de ressources afin que chacun chacune et
chacun puisse établir son budget
maintenant j'aurais souhaité en quelques
instants pouvoir évoquer quelques enjeux
plus généraux de cette réforme encore en
devenir
les entreprises clairement son
bénéficiaire
plus largement que prévu d'une réforme
conçue pour elle je me rappelle lorsque
l'assemblée nationale a transmis au
sénat le projet de loi de finances pour
2010 le gouvernement évalué à 4,3
milliards d'euros
l'allégement de charges fiscales devant
résulter de la réforme pour les
entreprises aujourd'hui à partir
d'évaluations plus in mais pas encore
définitive et compte tenu de la décision
du conseil constitutionnel
ce montant n'est plus de 4,3 milliards
d'euros mais bien de 5,3 milliards
d'euros
en revanche les données actuelles les
informations dont nous avons
connaissance ne perd ne nous permettent
pas d'avoir une idée vraiment précise
des effets de la réforme par taille
d'entreprises par secteurs d'activité ni
même d'ailleurs au niveau de chaque
entreprise considérés individuellement
une étude approfondie reste à conduire
sur les conséquences de l'introduction
dans la loi d'une définition aussi
détaillée de la valeur ajoutée et pour
en revenir à la trajectoire de la
réforme
je voudrais rappeler un point
particulier celui relatif aux modalités
de taxation des titulaires de bénéfices
non commerciaux de moins de cinq
salariés leur sort fiscal devra être
tranché dès le projet de loi de finances
pour 2011
je rappelle simplement à ce sujet que ce
sont 400 millions d'euros qui manquaient
à l'appel pour le bloc communal
du côté de l'état madame le ministre
permettez moi de dire ou plutôt de
redire car c est un propos que j'ai
souvent répété cette réforme c'est un
pari à 5,3 milliards d'euros par an de
déficit structurel supplémentaires le
montant des gains des entreprises c'est
à due concurrence
la perte de recettes durable pour l'état
5,3 milliards d'euros
on a donc accepté afin de poursuivre un
objectif d'intérêt général de dégrader
l'eau d'autant le déficit structurel
ce qui par définition complique les
conditions du retour au respect des
critères du pacte de stabilité et de
croissance compte tenu de l'évolution de
notre dette et des problèmes
particulièrement préoccupant de nos
finances publiques il y a lieu de
d'avoir une vue plus général des choses
et ce sera la fonction du débat
d'orientation sur les finances publiques
qui au sénat va se tenir le jeudi 8
juillet prochain pour 2010 venant sans
doute opportunément en relais du plan de
relance budgétaire il s'agit bien d'un
effet favorable sur la trésorerie des
entreprises de l'ordre de 12 milliards
d'euros et ceux ci assurément est un
soutien précieux pour la sortie de crise
en définitive mes chers collègues la
réforme fera l'objet d'évaluations son
succès devra être appréciée un jour à
l'aune des objectifs au nom desquels on
a pris le risque de temps bouleverser le
système de financement local
il s'agit bien de lever les freins à
l'investissement de lutter contre la
désindustrialisation
nous verrons nous apprécierons en temps
utile dans l'avenir le point de savoir
si les résultats sont proportionnelles à
l'argent investi et aux risques pris
pour conclure je souhaiterais mes chers
collègues remercié par
culièrement le président du sénat gérard
larcher et la conférence des présidents
d'avoir inscrit notre proposition de
résolution en ouverture de la discussion
du projet de loi relatif aux
collectivités territoriales
car si l'on se résume quels sont les
enjeux aujourd'hui pour les
collectivités territoriales elles sont
manifestement soumise à plusieurs
phénomènes contradictoires auquel il va
leur falloir faire face simultanément la
nécessité de rénover leur système de
financement pour tirer les conséquences
de la disparition de la taxe
professionnelle la réduction de leurs
marges de manoeuvre fiscales du fait
pour le moment de l'absence de pouvoir
de taux sur la cotisation sur la valeur
ajoutée des entreprises
la réduction de leur autonomie fiscale
dès lors que la part des dotations dont
le financement local en substitut de la
taxe professionnelle est sensiblement
plus élevé qu'il n'était prévu lorsque
nous avons voté la réforme
cette part de dotation le montant que
l'état doit apporter pour équilibrer le
système était évalué à 600 millions
d'euros et devrait être plutôt de 2 5
milliards d'euros et cette somme se
bloque
nous pouvons penser qu'il sera
stabilisée qu'il n'évoluera pas comme la
réalité économique
parmi les préoccupations des
collectivités territoriales figure vous
le savez la forte augmentation des
dépenses obligatoires notamment dans le
domaine social et en ce qui concerne les
budgets départementaux
il faut aussi évoquer dans la
conjoncture actuelle et dans le cadre de
la consolidation budgétaire que nous
devons engager la stabilisation en
valeur du montant des concours
financiers que verse l'état à l'ensemble
des collectivités territoriales et tout
ceci devant être cohérent avec les
options générales
du programme de stabilité 2010 2013 et
prendre place dans le cadre des
nouvelles règles de gouvernance
budgétaire dont notre pays a besoin pour
inspirer confiance à l'extérieur alors
au total madame le ministre mes chers
collègues
les auteurs de la proposition de
résolution souhaiterez souhaite
réaffirmer dans un esprit bien entendu
très constructif leur vive préoccupation
à l'égard des résultats encore non
maîtrisée d'une réforme économiquement
utile à court terme mais dont les effets
structurels ne sont pas encore explicité
c'est une réforme qui au demeurant nous
devons en être conscients n'aurait pas
été possible sans les adaptations voulue
par le parlement et les réécritures
successives de l'assemblée nationale et
du sénat
et c'est donc avec le souhait d'une
vigilance toute particulière mais aussi
bien entendu avec amitié et confiance
que nous nous adressons à vous pour vous
demander de bien vouloir entendre nos
préoccupations
merci de votre attention merci philippe
marini alors dans la suite du débat la
parole est à bernard véra
la vague du point
c'est le président comme la ministre mes
chers collègues
l'article 34 de la constitution
directement issue de la révision
constitutionnelle de juillet 2008
nouveau aujourd'hui de débattre d'une
proposition de résolution dont la portée
normative et par nature limités en effet
son adapte son adoption n'emporte aucune
obligation pour le gouvernement et
l'affichage purement politique de
l'exercice est donc ainsi affirmer une
telle démarche présente d'ailleurs quand
à la question posée un caractère assez
particulier car le texte de proposer non
seulement ne presse pas le gouvernement
de mettre en oeuvre la clause de
revoyure élément essentiel de la loi de
finances pour 2010 mais de plus il le
dédouane par avance de ne pas avoir tenu
ses engagements
notre groupe crc spg avait exprimé
l'automne dernier les plus grandes
réserves sur la réforme des finances
locales avec particulièrement la
suppression de la taxe professionnelle
et la mise en oeuvre d'une contribution
économique territoriale dont le
rendement attendu était prévu comme
sensiblement plus faibles la proposition
de résolution nous présente cette
réforme comme le fruit d'une longue
concertation avec l'ensemble des élus
locaux et de leurs associations
il suffit de lire nombre de bulletins
municipaux et de revues d'associations
d'élus et de voir les initiatives menées
par des conseils généraux confrontés aux
transferts de charges pour mesurer
chaque jour la qualité de cette
concertation bien des inquiétudes se
sont d'ailleurs manifesté devant les
modes de calcul des nouvelles ressources
des collectivités locales
nombre de communes et
d'intercommunalités certains
départements et certaines régions se
prouvant écrêté alors même que la
situation de leurs finances ou celle de
leurs habitants ne justifiait pas a
priori une telle situation
ainsi pour ne donner qu'un exemple de la
réforme des finances locales une région
comme la reine
ont faiblement doté à l'origine de taxe
professionnelle se retrouvent écrêté
temps au titre du budget départemental
qu'au titre du budget régional par
accroissement mécanique de la richesse
supposée de la collectivité par
intégration des impôts ménages
nous avions proposé lors de la
discussion d'un récent collectif
budgétaire compte tenu de la situation
sociale difficile de la population et du
faible pourcentage de revenus imposables
de prévoir que les départements et
collectivités d'outre-mer ne soit pas
concernée par l'écrêtement de leurs
ressources au titre du fonds national de
garantie
quelle contradiction en effet de voir
des collectivités bénéficiant de manière
normale et naturelle d'une dotation
globale de fonctionnement modifiés se
retrouver avec une amputation de leurs
maigres ressources fiscales et les
exemples fourmillent dans l'ensemble des
collectivités des effets pour le moins
pervers de cette suppression de la taxe
professionnelle c'est ce premier
problème que pose cette réforme des
finances locales
décidément mal parti ceci dit les
collectivités qui vont bénéficier du
concours du fonds garantis ne sont pas
mieux lotis tout simplement parce que la
dotation versée par le fonds de garantie
sera maintenue en euros courants et que
le pouvoir d'achat de la dotation est
appelé à se réduire
année après année parce qu'elle ne
prendra pas en compte la progression de
ce qui aurait constitué les bases de
taxe professionnelle
permettez moi de trouver quelques
éléments de contradictions dans la
manière dont la proposition de
résolution appréhende la clause de
revoyure la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle s'accompagne d'une
absence relevé d'ailleurs par le rapport
durieux des outils de péréquation c'est
le cas notamment du devenir des fonds
départementaux et du fonds de solidarité
des communes de la région ile-de-france
dont les moyens étaient fournis par
écrêtement de la taxe professionnelle
des établissements exceptionnelles et
des communes les plus largement pourvue
en base d'imposition
le problème c'est que le devenir de la
péréquation ne peut passer par une seule
démarche horizontale
organisant la solidarité entre
collectivités prétendument riche et
collectivités présumé plus pauvres et ce
alors même que la matière fiscale
continue de procéder de l'activité
économique surtout dans un contexte où
le gouvernement annonce avant même la
discussion de la loi de finances 2011 un
gel des dotations budgétaires aux
collectivités locales
on ne sait toujours pas si la
suppression de la taxe professionnelle
est bénéfique pour l'emploi mais on
décide tout de même de mettre les élus
devant le fait accompli on les invite à
se serrer la ceinture
notons d'ailleurs que la proposition de
résolution met en évidence dans l'exposé
des motifs que la nouvelle répartition
des compétences entre collectivités
n'étant pas abouti on ne saurait fixer
définitivement les conditions de la
péréquation des ressources l'impression
demeure donc que la suppression de la
taxe professionnelle pose in fine est
bien plus de problèmes qu'elle n'en a
vraiment résolu alors comment
interpréter une situation qui conduit la
majorité de notre assemblée à se déjuger
et a recommandé de reporter à une date
ultérieure l'examen des correctifs d'une
réforme aussi mal engagée
les simulations et l insuffisante à
l'été 2009 au moment de la suppression
de la taxe professionnelle ne
s'arrêteront pas entre février et
novembre 2009 que cette suppression
allait emporter la suppression des fonds
départementaux de péréquation dont les
ressources sont pourtant essentiels aux
petites communes rurales et aux
établissements publics de coopération
intercommunale pour mener à bien leur
politique d'aménagement et d'équipement
il n'y aurait donc que la suppression de
la taxe professionnelle
allez poser un problème majeur aux
communes de la région ile de france où
les inégalités sociales et territoriales
sont six accusés que la disparition du
moindre outil de péréquation est un
facteur d'aggravation de ses inégalités
il est évident que ces risques ses
conséquences étaient connus et que de
fait seul importait pour le gouvernement
comme pour sa majorité parlementaire de
supprimer la taxe professionnelle
pour faire droit à une revendication du
medef la disparition de la taxe
professionnelle un double défaut le
premier c'est que la mesure diminue
gravement la capacité d'innovation
politique et budgétaire des
collectivités locales en rigidifiant une
bonne partie des ressources fiscales de
chaque échelon de collectivités
la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle réduit les marges de
manoeuvre dont dispose des assemblées
locales élues pour mener des politiques
de développement correspondant aux
attentes des habitants
cette pseudo réforme conduit à confiner
l'action publique locale sur les seules
dépenses obligatoires dépenses découlant
comme chacun le sait pour une part
croissante des transferts de l'état non
compensés le fait que la proposition de
résolution au fasse état de la situation
dramatique de nombreux départements en
quasi cessation de paiement suffit à le
prouver
le défaut de la réforme c'est que la
suppression de la taxe professionnelle
n'a qu'un impact réduit sur le niveau de
la fiscalité des entreprises dans notre
pays s'il est vrai que cette taxe était
unique en europe
elle ne faisait toutefois que compléter
un cadre fiscal globalement allégée pour
les entreprises dans un pays où le
rendement de l'impôt sur les sociétés
est particulièrement faible au regard
d'autres pays
et ce n'est pas affaire de taux mais
sans doute d'assiette alors reposons la
question
supprimer la taxe professionnelle est ce
bon pour l'emploi et l'investissement
est ce suffisant pour modifier les
stratégies d'entreprise sur ces points
précis
les chiffres trimestriels du chômage
nous indique que nous approchons des 2,8
millions de chômeurs catégorie 1 pour
l'emploi revient de rendre publique
l'enquète sur l'emploi salarié qui
indique notamment que l'industrie
présenté comme principales bénéficiaires
de la réforme a encore supprimé 32 1400
postes de travail au premier trimestre
et que ces suppressions n'ont été que
partiellement compensé par le recours à
l'intérim
redevenu
variable d'ajustement des coûts de
production et pour compléter l'enquète
pour l'emploi la faible croissance
économique enregistrée depuis le début
de l'année suffirait sans doute à
montrer que les mauvaises habitudes de
gestion des entreprises n'ont pas varié
d'un millimètre taxe professionnelle ou
pas ce qui réduit la proposition de
résolution à une opération de diversion
faire croire aux élus locaux qu'on
entend leurs inquiétudes
alors que dès octobre 2010 nombre de
villes auront amené d'heure débat
d'orientation budgétaire sans disposer
d'éléments fiables
c'est donc une initiative directement
politiques ont pris en commun les
présidents des groupes ump et union
centriste
mais elle a au moins deux défauts l'un
nous l'avons souligné c'est celui de
dédouaner par avance au gouvernement de
ne pas avoir tenu ses engagements
c'est-à-dire de présenter avant le 31
juillet 2010 un texte d'adaptation des
conditions de mise en oeuvre de la
réforme des finances locales
un texte que le droit d'initiative
parlementaire devrait d'ailleurs à notre
sens soumettre au débat sans tarder et
l'autre c'est de négliger l'aspiration
des élus à la clarté et à la levée des
incertitudes sur l'avenir en repoussant
la clause de revoyure
c'est d'une réforme mal négocié dont les
effets ne sont pas probants sauf pour le
déficit de l'état et l'amélioration de
la rentabilité des entreprises et
causant bien des tourments aux élus
locaux que cette proposition de
résolution nous invite finalement
accepté les termes et c'est pourquoi le
groupe crc spg de la votera pas merci
bernard véra nous poursuivons avec le
président nicolas à bout
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues pour la première
fois le sénat examine aujourd'hui une
proposition de résolution présentée en
application de l'article 34 de la
constitution pour comprendre le sens de
cette initiative commune des groupes ump
et union centriste
il faut je crois à revenir un instant
sur les étapes qui ont jalonné la
réforme de la taxe professionnelle
la première étape c'est bien sûr
l'annoncera président de la république
en février 2009 de la suppression de cet
impôt
la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle était nécessaire depuis
sa création trop de réformes successives
1 avaient altéré peut-être l'intérêt
pourtant excellentes réalisations en
2009 il pesé sur les équipements et
biens mobiliers des entreprises donc les
investissements productifs étaient taxés
avant même qu'il n'ait produit le
moindre euro de richesse cela signifié
qu'il n'y a plus une entreprise
investisse et plus elle a quitté un
montant important de taxe
professionnelle la suffisance de
l'investissement français le vaste
mouvement d industrialisation de nos
territoires et la multiplication des
délocalisations justifié donc par
logique économique la suppression
urgente de ce prélèvement
au delà de sa justification logique
supprimer cet impôt s'imposer également
par nécessité l'amélioration de la
compétitivité française exige que l'on
réduise les charges qui pèsent sur les
entreprises et la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle était un des derniers
leviers fiscaux que législateur pouvait
tenter d'actionner en ce sens
pourtant cette réforme dans sa forme
initiale était inacceptable elle menacée
le tènement fiscale et financière des
collectivités elle ne garantissait pas
des ressources stables dynamique et
prévisible l'assemblée nationale à
améliorer le texte notamment en
instaurant un lien fiscal direct entre
entreprises et collectivités en affecte
20% du produit de cette cotisation au
bloc communal compte tenu de son
importance et de sa complexité le groupe
union centriste du sénat ont refusé
d'examiner cette réforme à
l'emporte-pièce il a donc été décidé de
découpler l'examen de l'article 2 en
deux volets grâce au temps de réflexion
cet examen en deux temps a permis de
dégager et grâce au remarquable travail
accompli par la commission des finances
du sénat
l' architecture de la réforme et la
répartition des ressources entre niveaux
de collectivités ont été profondément
revue et améliorée
récit d'un problème de taille
il nous était demandé de bouleverser la
fiscalité locale sans que l'on puisse
mesurer dans le détail toutes les
conséquences de la réforme notamment le
montant des recettes que percevrait
chaque catégorie de collectivité le
délai prévu par la constitution pour
examiner et adopter le projet de loi de
finances rendait impossible
l'élaboration de simulations détaillées
basé sur le dispositif proposé par la
commission des finances lors de l'examen
du second volet de la réforme notre
groupe a donc défendu deux clauses de
revoyure
la première d'entre elle interviendra en
2011 lorsque les collectivités
territoriales auront pu constater
concrètement les essais de la réforme
comme l'a souligné le président de la
république au maire qu'il a reçus le 20
novembre 2009 il importe de mesurer
l'impact des récentes voté par le
parlement
non seulement avant mais surtout après
leur mise en oeuvre effective la seconde
clause de revoyure que nous avons tenu à
inscrire à l'article 76 loi de finances
aura lieu après la réforme des
compétences des collectivités pour
adapter les ressources de chaque niveau
en conséquence une troisième clause de
revoyure également nécessaire à nos yeux
a été introduite à la loi de finances
pour adapter le dispositif de
répartition des ressources dès 2010
ont vu les simulations détaillées or mes
chers collègues le premier de ces rendez
vous était prévu au 1er juin afin que la
loi adapte une première fois le
dispositif avant le 31 juillet prochain
dès le 3 juin par la voix de notre
collègue yves détraigne le groupe union
centriste s'étonner que le rapport qui
devait être transmis au parlement avant
le 1er juin ne l'est pas été et
interroger le gouvernement sur ce point
ces questions sont malheureusement
restées sans réponse la première d'entre
elles c'est évidemment le calendrier de
révision de la réforme que le
gouvernement entend mettre en oeuvre
et c'est précisément l'objet de cette
proposition de résolution
la deuxième porte sur l'insuffisance des
dispositifs de péréquation souligné par
rapport durieux qui a finalement été
présenté en commission des finances la
semaine dernière et sur les
améliorations que le gouvernement entend
apporter aux mécanismes de péréquation
prévu dans la loi de finances pour 2010
la troisième question plus large mais
tout aussi importante porte sur les
mesures que compte prendre le
gouvernement pour permettre aux
collectivités locales de continuer par
leur investissement à jouer leur rôle de
soutien à l'économie française
il y a urgence à apporter des réponses à
ses interrogations car on peut craindre
que le gel des dotations ajoutée aux
incertitudes qui pèsent sur l'évolution
de la fiscalité locale ne pousse les
élus à adopter une position d'attenté
aujourd'hui nombre d'élus locaux le
demande dans quelles conditions elles
pourront préparer leur budget de l'année
prochaine sachant que la compensation
n'était prévu que pour 2010 voilà mes
chers collègues les principales raisons
qui motivent à nos yeux cette
proposition de résolution
cette initiative commune est aussi
l'occasion de rappeler à cette tribune
que les collectivités détiennent que 11%
la dette publique tout en assurant 73 %
de l'investissement public
elles ne sont pas les premiers
responsables de la situation des
finances
blick de notre pays qui contribuent
peut-être elle nous offre également
l'occasion d'attirer votre attention
madame la ministre sur la nécessaire
évolution de la dotation globale de
fonctionnement
la dgf pour laquelle il subsiste un
élément forfaitaire qui date de 1992 est
une injustice notamment entre
départements ruraux
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
tenu à ce que les clauses de revoyure
permettent d'améliorer sa vocation
perret quattre is me seront très
attentifs madame la ministre répond ce
que vous nous apporterez à ce sujet la
semaine dernière lors des questions
cribles thématiques portant sur la crise
financière européenne
notre collègue françois zocchetto a
regretté que les hypothèses retenues
d'un programme de stabilité transmis par
la france à bruxelles en février dernier
ne soit pas aussi crédible nous
pourrions le souhaitez bien pire encore
il a déploré qu'elle ne soit pas
cohérente avec les hypothèses retenues
dans la programmation annexé au
programme au projet de loi de finances
pour 2010 alors mes chers collègues les
simulations du rapport durieux ont été
bâties sur les hypothèses de croissance
économique très audacieuse que la france
a transmises à la commission européenne
elle pourtant semblé logique que les
simulations prévu à l'article 76 loi de
finance repose sur les prévisions
établies dans cette même loi de finances
cela nous semblait si évident que nous
n'avons pas pris le soin de le préciser
eh bien nous avons eu tort se souhaite
donc vous interrogez madame a misé sur
la crédibilité de ces hypothèses de
croissance
vous le savez cette question de la plus
haute importance pour nos collectivités
territoriales puisque le produit de la
contribution sur la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises en dépendra et pour conclure
pour éviter toute confusion pour quelque
chose dont je sois très claire
aujourd'hui nous indiquons expréssement
que les simulations preview neuvième
alinéa de la résolution devront
évidemment reposer sur des hypothèses
macroéconomiques crédibles et cohérentes
avec la plus récente loi de finances
merci de votre attention
merci président
la parole est à nicole bricq
madame la ministre
shark collègues au moment où le texte
sur la réforme des collectivités
territoriales revient en deuxième
lecture au sénat
nous l'aborderons nuitamment
nous ignorons le sort final qui sera
réservé au conseiller territorial et à
son mode d'élection
mesure phare du gouvernement est ainsi
que le sort qui sera réservé à la
rédaction de l'assemblée nationale
concernant les champs respectifs des
compétences des collectivités locales
mais nous sommes sûrs d'une chose c'est
que celle ci les collectivités locales
sont d'ores et déjà contrainte à
l'austérité sous le double effet de la
perte d'autonomie fiscale actée par la
loi de finances pour 2010 et du gel en
valeur des dotations financières qui
nous est annoncée pour celle qui arrive
pour 2011
si l'on y ajoute l'absence de lisibilité
contenu un de la perte de la taxe
professionnelle de de la méconnaissance
du produit réel d impôt de remplacement
singulièrement la cotisation sur la
valeur ajoutée les y faire 3 de
l'incertitude qui pèse sur la
réévaluation des bases
les menaces sont lourdes
la péréquation grande oubliée de la loi
de finances restent à quai alors que la
cour des comptes a rappelé les
inégalités criantes préexistant à la
réforme inégalités que le gouvernement
gelée dans la loi de finances pour 2010
puisque le mode de compensation les
retient tels que et il ne faut pas
confondre de toute façon compensation et
péréquation et la péréquation est
particulièrement nécessaire en ile de
france
compte tenu du cumul des inégalités
territoriales et des inégalités sociales
je rappelle que le fonds de solidarité
de la région ile de france qui est le
seul mécanisme de péréquation
horizontale entre communes dites riches
et communes dites pauvres et bien a
disparu avec la taxe professionnelle et
ne dispose d'aucune revoyure alors à
posteriori la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle était bien l'acte un
fondateur du projet du gouvernement à
l'encontre des collectivités
territoriales le pari du gouvernement
est limpide
désormais les collectivités seront
forcés de s'ajuster au nouveau cadre
financier dans lequel elles évolueront
désormais et la crise n'aura été qu'une
justification a posteriori de ce schéma
est pourtant que n'avait-on entendu côté
gouvernement lors de l'examen de la loi
de finances pour 2010 que nous invitons
inscrit dans le texte à l'article 76
côté majorité
nous devions disposer d'un rapport avant
le 1er juin avec les simulations
détaillées des recettes et avant le 31
juillet
la fameuse clause de revoyure réclamée
par nombre d'entre vous devez préciser
le mode de répartition locales ainsi que
la mise en place de la péréquation
dès le 2 20 le groupe socialiste a
dénoncé le non respect de ce double
engagement gouvernemental le ministre du
budget françois baroin a confirmé
l'enterrement de la rue
les murs en déclarant le 17 juin à notre
en réponse à une question d'actualité
posée par notre collègue jacques mézard
au sénateur du cantal membres du groupe
rdse
il a répondu que finalement la clause de
revoyure se déroulerait au fil de
l'évolution de la préparation budgétaire
elle était donc officiellement enterrée
par cette déclaration
il nous faut en conclure que le
gouvernement entend en 2011 pour suivre
la compensation 2011
après il ya 2012 avec une échéance
électorale majeure et il le fera au prix
habituel d'une impasse budgétaire de 5
milliards 300 millions au moment où le
même gouvernement annonce qu'il va faire
la chasse aux déficits
eh bien on continuera à payer cette
impasse budgétaire en empruntant sur les
marchés financiers pour une réforme qui
madame la ministre c'était votre vos
interventions répétées qui était censé
doper la compétitivité des entreprises
la preuve de l'intérêt de cette mesure
pour le but que vous avez affiché ne
nous a jamais été fournie je me rappelle
même que le président de la république
dit les délocalisations vont cesser avec
la perte de la taxe professionnelle
on sait ce qu'il en est de ce type de
propos deux tribunes
dès lors chers collègues
de l'ump et du centre la proposition de
résolution que vous nous soumettez
apparaît comme un simulacre
il faut bien utiliser le terme de cette
revoyure tant voulu par une partie de la
majorité du reste je ne vois pas le chef
des frondeurs à sa place habituelle sur
les bancs de la majorité et pourtant ils
devraient être parmi nous et car c'était
quand même si nous avions bien compris
le prix à payer pour les frondeurs pour
qu'ils votent ce texte est monsieur
raffarin avait du reste utilisé le terme
de période probatoire jusqu'à la remise
de ce fameux rapport
donc il s'agit bien d'un simulacre
car il s'agit d'actes et le report de
toute discussion sur le fond et nous ne
sommes même pas assuré de l'amour de
l'avoir pour la loi de finances pour
que faut-il attendre de cette procédure
nouvelles introduites par la réforme
constitutionnelle de 2008
pas grand chose car elle ne donne lieu
ni à examen en commission ni à un
amendement par simulacre nous entendons
bien un nouvel écran de fumée qui acte
le non respect de l'engagement pris
devant et par le parlement le
gouvernement et sans solution mais on
s'interroge sur sa volonté à rechercher
une telle solution
madame la ministre votre audition du 22
juin devant la commission des finances
élargie et est éclairante
vous vous en êtes remise le plus souvent
pour répondre à la mission de nos
collègues sénateurs et députés qui au
passage sont tous de la même couleur
puisqu'ils sont tous membres de de l'ump
et ce faisant vous vous défausser encore
sur les parlementaires toute embellie
en lavaux à unique qui est celle de la
restriction et de l'austérité alors si
l'on savait en décembre dernier quand
nous discutions de la loi de finances
que l'on ne disposerait pas à tant de
chiffres précis pour effectuer des
simulations sérieuse pourquoi avoir
promis ces contretemps était largement
prévisible d'autant que les entreprises
elles mêmes ont eu des difficultés à
faire leurs déclarations concernant ce
qu'on entendait par périmètre de la
valeur ajoutée et bien au delà des
frondeurs dont il fallait obtenir
l'assentiment il s'agissait en fait pour
le gouvernement l'an passé de rassurer
le corps électoral dessinateur et plus
largement les élus locaux soutenant la
majorité je ne suis pas sûr que vous y
êtes arrivés les uns et les autres nous
sommes dans dans nos départements
à écouter entendre les élus que nous
représentons qu'ils soient de droite ou
de gauche et je pense que l'un qui les
élus de gauche qu'ils avaient compris
très vite et les huiles droite je crois
que leurs yeux ce sont d'essayer au fur
à mesure des annonces qui leur était
faite
en clair c'était une manoeuvre et nous
avons eu raison de la dénoncer très tôt
alors le gouvernement a finalement remis
le 17 juin un rapport qui ne fait que
reprendre le rapport de bruno durieux
il ne craint il ne contient pas à la
date du 17 juin les les résultats des
analyses et des simulations qui avait
été demandé par les commissions la
commission des finances et
singulièrement celle demandée par le
groupe socialiste sénatorial tué environ
ou alors elles ont finalement été
transmises envoyé quand même que nos
collègues le sache
parce que c'est obligatoire pour
l'application du règlement
intérieur c'est mon président de groupe
qui me le rappeler qui fait qu' il faut
avoir ces simulations la veille de du
débat sur une proposition de résolution
et donc elles ont été envoyées en date
du 25
le 25 septembre androni et elles ont été
reçues avec le tampon de la commission
des finances le dimanche 27
hier autant dire que comme il n'y a pas
d'examen en commission et même s'il y en
avait eu 1
nous n'aurions pas été en capacité de
les analyser que vraiment c'était pour
respecter le règlement intérieur et ne
pas se mettre en faute
donc je reviens sur ces simulations réel
elles sont indispensables pour évaluer
l'efficacité des dispositifs de
péréquation imaginables vous connaissez
notre attachement groupe socialiste à
traiter globalement de la fiscalité
locale notamment en introduisant le
revenu dans l'assiette de la taxe
d'habitation
on ne pourra pas nous reprocher comme
vous l'avez fait trop souvent collègues
de la majorité et notamment le président
du groupe majoritaire ump de ne pas
faire de propositions sur quelle base
pourrions nous les faire et précisément
nous ne connaissons pas l'effet base car
le gouvernement s'était aussi engagé sur
le fond a entamé la révision des bases
et madame la ministre le 22 juin devant
la commission des finances vous nous
avez confirmé poursuivre l' idée qui
avait été avancée par monsieur woerth
quand il était ministre du budget d'une
révision des bases échelonnées dans le
temps au fil de l'eau comme on dit en
commençant par celle des entreprises et
nous vous avons nous groupe socialiste
on a toujours été contre cette méthode
car nous craignons avec cette méthode
une nouvelle
esti ce au détriment des ménages et une
fiscalité locale qui loin d'être
simplifiée sera encore plus complexe si
on saucissonne l'arrêt ou la révision
des bases en commençant par les
entreprises
alors sur le fond la proposition de
résolution se réfugie une fois encore
une fois dans l'incantation quand elle
réaffirme je la cite l'attachement à la
territorialisation de la contribution
sur la valeur ajoutée son corollaire la
péréquation par le d'or le rédacteur je
rappelle que la territorialisation si
elle est acté pour le bloc communal ne
l'est que très partiellement pour les
départements et les régions
si je me souviens c'est à hauteur de 22%
la mutualisation et son ampleur pose un
problème à très court terme il nous faut
en effet apprécier l'efficacité de tel
ou tel dispositif
par exemple quels sont les effets
comparer d'une mutualisation des
ressources et/ou d'un prélèvement a
posteriori il faut pouvoir l'apprécier
parce que en fonction de simulation que
nous ne connaissons pas la position peut
être différente et il est acté que tous
les dispositifs de péréquation ne
peuvent pas entrer en vigueur en 2011
j'en veux pour preuve la réponse du
gouvernement à la question de notre
collègue sénateur du groupe socialiste
rachel mazuir où le gouvernement a
annoncé que le fonds de péréquation des
droits de mutation à titre onéreux ne
seraient actionnées ne sera actionné
qu'en 2012 donc il n'y aura pas de
péréquation pour 2011 et tout est à
l'avenant
ainsi et je voudrais quand même en dire
un mot le premier ministre a reçu les
représentants des départements plus
qu'un pied devant leurs difficultés
financières et j'entendais ce matin
notre collègue député et président du
conseil général de la seine saint denis
qui
avec l'âpreté qu'on lui connaît mène une
bataille légitime sur ce terrain et je
veux y faire écho le premier ministre
leur a annoncé un projet de loi avant de
la fin de l'année sur le cinquième
risque
ce qui nous laisse quand même sceptique
sur l'échéance annoncée en 2011
et quant à leurs difficultés financières
il serait prévu un système contractuel
au terme duquel les départements en
difficulté recevrait des avances
remboursables
alors ça nous conduit à dire qu'on
entend que le gouvernement entend régler
un problème structurel qui n'est pas de
la responsabilité des départements
ils sont responsables ni de l'évolution
de la démographie ni du marché de
l'emploi et donc il le gouvernement
entend régler ce problème structurel par
une solution purement conjoncturelle
cette proposition n'est donc pas de
nature à régler la hausse inexorable des
dépenses sociales
pour terminer il faut souligner que la
sous-évaluation du coût de la
compensation de la perte de la taxe
professionnelle aux collectivités
locales dans la loi de finances initiale
mise en lumière à la suite du rapport
durieux et de son examen par le comité
des finances locales le 1er juin je
crois a conduit vous a conduit madame la
ministre a justifié l'écart de chiffrage
par courrier joint au rapport adressé le
17 juin la commission des finances parce
qu'en effet on est passé d'une
estimation initiale acté dans la loi de
finances de 800 millions a finalement 2
milliards 5 et vous avez vous avez
répondu vous êtes vous êtes justifier de
cette évolution
mais je regrette faute avouée n'est pas
pardonnable
car nous sommes trop habitués au
parlement à cette très mauvaise habitude
de sous-évaluation d'une charge par le
l'économie et des finances quand cela
arrange le gouvernement comme de
surévaluation quand la mesure le dérange
mais ici l'intention politique était
clair dès le départ il fallait calmer
les craintes des élus en écoutant les
nôtres aussi bien que les votes je doute
que vous ayez atteint votre but alors
nous reprendrons ce débat lors des
orientations budgétaires d'ici peu qui
pour la première fois d'ici peu c'est la
semaine prochaine recevra la sanction du
vote et à l'automne
bien évidemment lors de la discussion du
projet de loi de finances qui devrait se
caler effectivement notre collègue à
bout a raison sur le programme de
stabilité transmis à bruxelles
et vous avez annoncé madame la ministre
que vous pratiquez auriez une révision
de l'hypothèse de croissance pour 2011
hypothèse complètement sur évalué à 2,5
et nous attendons donc vos propositions
en attendant la proposition de
résolution se contente de reprendre les
termes des clauses de revoyure
elle n'est même pas un rappel fait au
gouvernement du non respect de sa
promesse
pas plus que la manoeuvre initial cette
nouvelle manière
cette nouvelle manoeuvre mauvaises
manières ne nous trompe pas et donc nous
ne la cautionne rompt pas merci nicole
bricq
la parole est au président yvon cola
l'horizon
le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues de notre finances pour
2010 a donné naissance dans des
conditions déplorables que nous
connaissons à la contribution économique
territoriale censé remplacer la taxe
professionnelle
cette nouvelle contribution devait selon
les dires de ses promoteurs maintenir un
lien étroit entre les collectivités les
entreprises sans porter atteinte à la
compétitivité ni lier à l'activité de
ces derniers issus des engagements du
président de la république sur la base
de promesses faites au medef cette
réforme suscite un tel enthousiasme
qu'elle engendra même la réticence de la
majorité du sénat et de la commission
des finances
nous redoutions alors que se met en
place toutes les conditions d'un
appauvrissement des collectivités et
d'une perte d'autonomie fiscale en
violation de toutes les lois de
décentralisation impliqué depuis 1990 et
madame la ministre les faits continuent
de nous donner raison
on nous avait promis que la suppression
des textes profanes profits seraient ne
porterait en aucun cas atteinte à la
capacité financière des collectivités
d'assurer toutes leurs prérogatives
on nous avait promis que l'état se
porterait garant lanka de déficits
budgétaires locales et ce en dépit des
déficits budgétaires de l'état lui-même
on nous avait promis enfin que la
réforme allait entraîner une diminution
des délocalisations et une hausse de
l'activité des entreprises sur
l'ensemble de nos territoires
en vain que de promesses non tenues
toutefois la clause de revoyure adopté à
l'initiative d'un notre rapporteur
général et plus largement d'ailleurs du
sénat devait permettre de dresser un
premier bilan
en présentant les financements de
substitution qu attendent toujours les
collectivités à la lecture de l'article
76 de la loi de finances pour 2010
il était convenu
que le gouvernement transmette au
parlement avant le 1er juin dernier un
rapport présentant les simulations
détaillées des recettes de chaque
catégorie des collectivités leurs
variations à court moyen et long terme
ainsi qu'une estimation de l'évolution
des prélèvements locaux sur les
entreprises mais aussi sur les ménages
ce document était attendue par tous les
élus locaux avec une impatience doublée
d'une angoisse légitime
l'avenir de l'autonomie financière des
collectivités
effectivement et la vienne en jeu or
nous sommes le 28 juin et nous attendons
toujours
et d'ailleurs comme l'exprimé mon
excellent collègue jacques mézard lors
de la dernière séance de questions
d'actualité
le récent rapport durieux officiellement
remis par le gouvernement aux deux
assemblées ne saurait prétendre s'y
substituer il ne contient pas les
simulations promise est pourtant
essentiel il est d'ailleurs très
significative mes chers collègues que la
présente proposition de réseaux de
résolution constate elle même
l'insuffisance et les lacunes de ce
rapport puisque l appelle de ses voeux
la remise au vote de simulation non
seulement complémentaires mais aussi
actualiser et détails
ou comment reconnaître par la litote que
le rapport durieux n'est qu'un écran de
fumée avec lequel on voudrait aveugle et
le parlement les sénateurs du rdse et
les radicaux de gauche nous sommes pas
dupes
mais au delà notre débat dessus jours et
tout est surtout symptomatique des
conditions déplorables dans lesquelles
s'est opérée la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle
le plaidoyer pro domo des auteurs du
texte ne nous trompe pas il n'ya plus
qu'urgence à sauvegarder l'équilibré
bien fragile
les finances locales bien menacer les
perspectives financières sont ainsi
particulièrement inquiétante
le montant de la dotation de
compensation de la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle est d'ores et déjà
beaucoup plus imposant que prévu le
rapport durieux
pourtant mal calibré selon nous estime
déjà à plus de 2,5 milliards d'euros
soit près de 2 milliards de plus que des
évaluations du parlement de décembre
dernier alors que nous avons mis en
garde le gouvernement sur les effets de
la récession économique sur la future
cotisation sur la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises
aussi tout inquiétant sont les contours
des mécanismes de péréquation pourtant
prévu par la loi de finances pour 2010
or nous percevons depuis maintenant
plusieurs semaines déjà les vives
inquiétudes de tous les élus locaux
quant à leur prochain exercice
budgétaire
à cette heure les dispositifs de
péréquation régionale et départementale
ainsi que le cadre de péréquation entre
les communes mais aussi des
intercommunalités ne sont toujours pas
opération car le second outil qu'elle
sort adam la ministre sera réservé aux
ressources prévues notamment celles du
fonds départemental de péréquation de la
taxe professionnelle
madame le ministre nous percevons
aujourd'hui des conséquences funestes
d'une réforme mal préparée mal calibré
et mal mise en oeuvre nos collectivités
se retrouver tout fait
ne pouvant agir rapidement sur les frais
de fonctionnement elles sont contraintes
de geler nombre conséquent
d'investissements indispensables au bon
fonctionnement des services publics
locaux et au delà pour notre économie
ainsi ce qui aura été gagnée d'un côté
par la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle les entreprises le
perdront de l'autre par la baisse des
investissements et des commandes des
publics locaux une belle victoire à la
pyrrhus
quand on sait que 72% 72%
dm de l'investissement public provient
des collectivités madame le ministre
vous n'ignorez sans doute pas que
l'entente a semblé examine dès ce soir
en deuxième lecture le projet de loi de
réforme des collectivités territoriales
à l'incertitude financière s'ajoute donc
aussi l'incertitude institutionnelle
puisque nul ne sait aujourd'hui
le traitement qui sera réservé aux
collectivités quid des financements
croisés
quid des possibilités de subventions aux
plus petites communes puis de
l'autonomie fiscale des départements
sasso métropole
comment madame la ministre
envisagez-vous de faire évoluer le fn
geyer ou considérez vous que la
situation du fonds de garantie sera gelé
plusieurs années en attendant les
simulations sur le bloc communal ce qui
aggraverait de notre point de vue la
perte d'autonomie des collectivités
locales
car comment parler encore d'autonomie
financière des collectivités
quand les départements ne sont autonomes
que pour 12 % de leurs ressources
globales et les régions pour moins de 10
pour ça que vous ont fait les
collectivités
madame la ministre pour mériter un tel
traitement
dans ces conditions vous l'aurez compris
pour toutes ces raisons les radicaux de
gauche et la grande majorité des membres
du rds voteront contre cette proposition
de résolution
je vous remercie de votre carrière si
président colin la parole est à charles
guené
le bouchon
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues depuis le 1er
janvier 2010 les entreprises bénéficient
de la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle qui pesait anormalement
sur leur investissement
elles sont soumises aux nouveaux impôts
créée en remplacement et en particulier
à la contribution économique
territoriale et à les faire
l'imposition forfaitaire sur les
entreprises de réseaux les collectivités
territoriales ne percevront directement
ces nouvelles ressources qu'à compter de
en 2010 elles reçoivent de l'état une
compensation relais qui garantit le
maintien de leurs ressources de taxe
professionnelle et le système actuel
proroge cette garantie longtemps comme
l'a rappelé le seul rapporteur général
le sénat a apporté plus de souplesse et
de cohérence dans la mise en oeuvre de
la réforme
grâce à l'instauration de plusieurs
clauses de rendez vous législatifs
aux termes de l'article 76 de la loi de
finances pour 2010 doit intervenir la
première les trois clauses de revoyure
le sénat dans sa volonté de permettre au
parlement de remplir pas faire
parfaitement son rôle de législateur
mais aussi de garant de la ressource des
collectivités locales a souhaité que les
éléments de simulation et d'étude
d'impact fussent donner suffisamment en
amont et qu'une loi interviennent avant
fin juillet pour effectuer les
nécessaires inclinaison et le case était
échéant utiliser la loi de finances pour
en conforter les termes
force est de constater que nous avons
péché par optimisme en y at il eu
manoeuvres pour empêcher ce rendez vous
notre but est il désormais hors
d'atteinte le processus en est il pour
autant altérer ou dénaturer la sont les
véritables questions et cela bien au
delà au delà des effets de manche ou de
la volonté de nuire au bon
fonctionnement de la démocratie voire
même de pénaliser les collectivités
locales en usant de quelques a réussi
sans intérêts véritables de quoi est il
question
notre majorité
tenu à ce que cette réforme très
complexe soit assorti de clauses de
rendez-vous dans le temps afin que les
effets de la loi soit bien mesuré et les
corrections effectuées dès les
simulations faites c'est à dire après
application de la première partie celle
ci mi 2010 puis l'année suivante lorsque
la deuxième partie serait réalisée enfin
autant que le besoin lorsque les
transferts de compétences prévus par la
réforme des collectivités locales seront
connus et étudier notre majorité l'a
voulu alors que d'autres se sont
contentés de contester la réforme
elle y demeurent aujourd'hui plus que
jamais attachés à l'instar de l'ensemble
des élus de la république qui ont
d'ailleurs pu constater dès après la
première année de mise en oeuvre
où était la vérité et où se situait la
désinformation
où en sommes nous
l'article 76 prévoit que la loi précise
et adapte le dispositif de répartition
et met en place les mécanismes de
péréquation fondée sur les écarts de
potentialités de charge et cela au terme
d'un processus d'études et de rapports
fournis
si le gouvernement s'est entouré des
compétences nécessaires avec la mission
durieux il a produit les éléments avec
un léger retard d'environ 10 jours
encore que le contenu fut disponible dès
le 1er juin puisque les éléments
matériels étaient pour la plupart à
notre disposition et en ligne et je sais
que dans cet hémicycle chacun de nous a
mis à profit les dix jours de décalage
pour étudier tous les rapports parvenus
dans le détail il ne reste pas moins que
techniquement le processus n'était pas
complet puisque le comité des finances
locales consultés le 1er juin n'a rendu
qu'un avis partiel et a souhaité en
formuler un plus élaboré le sujet le 6
juillet prochain
par ailleurs les simulations n'ont pu
être réalisés que sur les bases de la
comptabilité publique puisque les
entreprises avaient jusqu'au 15 juin
pour déposer leur déclaration leurs
déclarations ce qui implique que les
éléments réels ne pourront donc être
collationner que postérieurement les
simulations en découlent en guerre à
montfa juillet accessoirement je
rappellerai que le rapport des
parlementaires en mission qui est
également apte
attendu par le cfl et je pense le
parlement devrait être remis le 30 juin
il reste que tous les rendu les
observateurs et conclusions des experts
aboutissent actuellement à une remise en
cause de la répartition globale des
ressources dans la mesure où l'
équilibre trouvé répond aux objectifs et
ne rompt pas utile une modification
général et surtout l'ensemble des élus a
pris en compte les données générales de
la garantie consentie et il serait donc
dangereux et très perturbant de revenir
une nouvelle fois sur ce schéma ce qui
n'oblige pas à une révision complète
donc de la loi mais à un examen des
problèmes identifiés
la première clause de revoyure doit donc
concerner les grandes lignes d'urgence
qui sont d'ores et déjà repéré il
importe d'établir au plus tôt de
nouveaux concepts de potentiel fiscal et
fonciers dans lequel sans lesquels
aucune réforme de péréquation ne serait
possible
pour le bloc communal et cela nécessite
du temps et de l'expertisé
les systèmes de péréquation pour les
départements et les régions doivent être
révisées ainsi que celles ce que
certains y faire et de cas de la
péréquation du bloc communal reste
vivement attendue et bien sûr les élus
doivent être rassurés quant au sort des
fonds départementaux de péréquation de
la taxe professionnelle et du stif
serions nous en mesure de le faire avant
fin juillet et encore plus voter un
texte
aucune personne de bonne foi ici ne se
risquerait à l'affirmer j'irai plus loin
j'entends déjà les vociférations qui
montrait ici et surtout leur devant
cette hat suspecte est totalement
aberrante à vouloir légiférer en aussi
peu de temps sur un sujet aussi complexe
est aussi important pour nos
collectivités locales car en fait
qu'avant nous avons nous entendu faire à
travers cette clause de revoyure
je m'adresse bien sûr à ses auteurs à
ceux qui soucieux de la bonne
élaboration de la loi on souhaitait
qu'elle existe
nous avons souhaité un temps de
réflexion des changes sérieux et de
débats sur les simulations réalisées sur
l' approche nouvelle les notions de
potentiel financier et sur les
paramètres d'une péréquation repensé
à titre personnel et sans vouloir
paraphraser un homme innus je pense que
les élus de france attendent autre chose
que de nous voir nous agiter comme des
cabris dans l'hémicycle au cri de clause
de revoyure clause de revoyure
ils veulent l'examen de cette
proposition de résolution sur la mise en
oeuvre de la contribution économique
territoriale un texte qui n'a donc pas
de valeur législative
mais comme l'a rappelé philippe marini
un des auteurs de cette proposition de
résolution l'objectif était pour les
parlementaires de faire part au
gouvernement des préoccupations des
sénateurs sur la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle
à ce jour ils estiment qu'ils n'ont pas
tous les éléments en main pour maîtriser
l'impact de cette réforme sur les
finances publiques
un texte donc sans valeur législative